clotilde provençal artiste plasticienne
souhaitent découvrir les métiers de
taxidermiste un travail qui consiste à
donner à la dépouille d'un animal une
apparence de vie la taxidermie est un
métier complet entre arts sciences et
pédagogie l'apprenti étudie les
nombreuses compétences techniques de ce
métier auprès de salim issac qui lui
transmet son savoir faire
salim et clotilde ont conçu un projet de
construction d'un buste de minotaure à
partir d'une vraie peau de taureaux
notre travail est déjà sûre à partir
d'une maquette en en
en plat still in qui est une espèce de
pâte à modeler avec de l'acier pour
pouvoir déterminer le volume de l'animal
et puis ensuite on a utilisé du
polystyrène qui est la base finalement
des sculptures
des sculptures animal et
donc donc 7
une tête de taureau également
qui est moulé dans du
dans de la mousse polyuréthane et là
nous allons poser la peau donc c'est la
prochaine étape un énorme travail de
dégraissage de la peau de nettoyage de
la est donc là elle est dans un bar de
tannage qui finalement la nettoie en
profondeur et puis là sous pli et la
préserve en fait fixe finalement les
bactéricide donc pour qu'elle puisse
être posée sans avoir de sans s'être
détériorée par la suite salini sacs et
les seuls à pratiquer la taxidermie à la
réunion le juge utile et important de
transmettre son savoir afin de faire
naître des vocations
elle a pris en premier à faire des
dessins de ce que voulait faire le gars
prélat fait une maquette à l'échelle en
place céline et après donc j'ai encore
on a commencé à faire la maquette en
polystyrène
donc je faisais la moitié elle faisait
l'autre moitié après chaque fois je
faisais de matière on faisait de moitié
pour qu'elles apprennent en même temps
le métier après elle a appris à
dépouiller 1
un taureau nettoyer la peau à utiliser
les bains chimiques et là on va préparer
la peau du taureau
donc elle va apprendre la pause et une
peau en taxidermie sur un support on
peut se tirer n'ai vu que je suis tout
seul aragon c'est bien que deux
personnes voient ce que je fais et
peuvent apprendre aussi à une vocation
taxidermie buquet n'a pas beaucoup donc
ça se trouve que je peux trouver à jour
une future collègue en taxes dernier je
fais comme j'ai fait moi je fais ils
regardent ils posent des questions et
puis s'ils ont l'âme manuel d'un mois
ils le comprennent tout de suite c'est
comme ça que moi j'ai appris
donc je fais passer comme ça de précieux
conseils pour clotilde qui s'enrichit de
la grande expérience du taxidermiste un
grand savoir faire parce que parce que
c'est un taxidermiste avéré qui a fait
beaucoup de beaucoup de pièces déjà au
niveau du musée donc c'est lui qui est
responsable de tout ce qui faillit c'est
lui qui a qui a constitué d'exposition
actuellement sur les requins mais aussi
sa spécialité c'est des oiseaux dont je
vais vous travaillez il m'a expliqué
toutes les techniques le minotaure fera
l'objet d'une exposition contemporaine
très prochainement